yo here we go
I am Gabbar Chuck come on Chuck who is
this you've done even enough many evils
around from all kinds of countries from
Russia to the USA to Bulgaria so we can
king the noona ji h3 this is getting
very popular I know that this is not
entirely correct but I just want a
different position here let's go for
this it's really a questionable line for
black but as I said a one side variety
here shoot to d3
[Music]
[Music]
yeah wonder is c4 a move that makes
sense yeah let's say castles and c4
system use for night coming to c5 not
sure really
let's do that
Bishop c4 Knight e4 I think should be
okay I don't know today I'm not the most
um yeah let's say a prolific Banco
gambit player ever and this is at least
Banco style no Knight c5 next
yeah I'm attacking this ok now 95
looking at E for if he has to go f3 this
is this is looking like I can pretend
for compensation okay yeah yes well
right for 95 95 d 3 something like that
interesting at least this is some messy
let's say ok um yeah I don't know here I
can just take B 5 I know a 7 is hanging
but well you can't have it all like here
fatigue on a1 and cheek B 5
I probably will get B 2 right so he
takes is 7 but this is not the greatest
greatest piece or whatever there on his
own and b2 hangs this is important check
[Music]
I still have 95 to d3 as a pretty active
option there no okay be - I can take b2
now still taking there there with the
Queen I guess rupee one Queen a Jew that
is quite nice actually for me I think I
wonder I wonder though or Queen c3 is
better Queen f6 is from the useless okay
let's go to a to have the same where I
should go I mean this is difficult the
same
yeah my position is quite an act affair
with this c-pawn but I don't see how I'm
going to going to use it maybe yeah 33
rue k1 is not possible
maybe Bishop d4 as possible that sets
that's true but a 93 looks quite good
oh I totally forgot about that one well
that's embarrassing and knowing the
allowing the the D pawn too too much Wow
yeah come on I have to be very dynamic
here and VT now this is no I'm really
quick with the pawn he has to keep this
protected and now see 342 and it's not
easy so I'm keeping this pawn and I
thought Queen e6 now maybe what do I
have something better
probably not but this is not bad
I'm keeping this pawn there under the
cover and I'm threatening work the eight
winning the pawn okay um t8 and I'm
winning the pawn I guess
I mean winning it back I'm a pawn down
at the moon but I have this this very
strong point that once III okay roopd
six he's checking me on a aid
26 and the end he puts the knight on d5
and they have to do this though I think
nothing nothing else I might play e5
actually u5 is strong now there maybe
it's stronger new I have Rupert III this
is actually not so clear
[Music]
okay f5 looks like the draw but can I
can I go for more I don't know if this
is this is warranted is he five that
stupid Yeti five I should have should
have forced the drone there that would
be would have been far more check far
more prudent time warning
[Music]
come on unfortunately it's just a job
[Music]
check yeah not much I could do there I
think I was there something here
I couldn't he could have that's very
strong
let's check okay this one here takes
yeah maybe I should end the whole thing
with that five this is this is a draw
that I mentioned you know just yeah and
I could just heck this and this is just
wrong even if you win see you Paul it's
just not clear that she doesn't just
dead yeah maybe I should have done that
but check don't risk anything here this
is a draw yeah well there was a stupid
way to player I really I totally forgot
that you can take c5 I really didn't
think about this computer says equal
which is kind of maybe this is fair I'm
very active there so it might be might
be the right assessment
okay drawing this 10ma game thanks for
watching